Barbie is available now on VUDU so head
to the link below to watch it
see you on the Malibu Beach
[Music]
the final epic can battle
is just how it sounds final it's epic
and it's a battle it went from being
this song that was maybe going to be
placed somewhere in the film to this
song that they built this kind of epic
battle around they have zero information
about what war is
[Music]
thank you
be riding on their horses
because they discovered the horses are
men extenders
and the weapon we have are dolls and the
cross sticks I instantly knew what the
can song should be and Greta is like we
love that song actually can you make it
longer so we're essentially scoring like
11 minutes just around the Ken song
growing up I loved the Nutcracker the
battle between the toy soldiers and the
Rats the absurdity of it that's
something I was thinking about when we
were creating this battle well stupid
and crazy it's crazy
just so Majestic that it causes the
Multiverse to implode
[Music]
the telephone game from The Real World
it's been distorted by the time it gets
back to them and they're just kind of
doing their best but it's it's really
the worst there's these two groups led
by Ryan and myself and
and going to
Warcraft I came up with the like concept
of having the fight mixed in with dance
the more ridiculous that we can make it
the better it's so ridiculous it's
it looks like it's slow motion
it's actually everyone's down
[Applause]
looks like using like that kid's
imagination where they create something
out of nothing like a chariot out of
umbrellas the dance stuff sort of fed in
from there
Duets a bit of Tango and like stupid
Movement Like missing punches but going
through the eyes
[Music]
we've been shooting kind of like this
arrival from the team Ryan from the
horse pedalos on the beach it was
to play that scene with beach balls and
soft weapons and rubber duckies with the
like commitment of a real war
[Music]
all over the place and people are going
down and getting stabbed by lacrosse
sticks and then all of a sudden Ryan and
I meet
this moment of the beach off
[Music]